I catch a bus second Bab Beck Beck last
time you know as in as you know and I
came we played rusty rails hotel which
was a phenomenal game it was actually
short about a bay now applying arrestor
it's rusty leg routes let's do this it's
beautiful all right
how do you know how do you make this
fullscreen nobody knows what's the tree
that falls grin okay that's that guy
wait wait okay there we go
rusty Lake spring 1860 James Van de boom
arrived at rusty Lake his uncle had just
axed away under mysterious circumstances
James was his uncle's only heir he had
no idea of the events that would change
his life
oh I can actually drag that's so weird
okay I don't know what that is
yeah okay I don't want no tutorial okay
about what I get what I get nothing
hello sir what you got there James are
get to formulate your uncle passed away
he has left your house and in a very
special say it I'm playing it inside
your own family's 5:7 - okay yeah right
yeah five yep
no actually at the drag I think five
seven okay tell dog bad I want that yeah
it's beautiful
okay can I go left now I can't
hello doggy yeah cap take this bout is
he gonna bury it God God Barrett
it's my spot now okay pike it gets water
panel I don't know if I like this whole
new scrolling thing get this out of my
way
I don't need instructions
[Music]
I can't Wallis bad my oh hey Zack my my
Mac dreams
wait is that done
oh I guess that's it down I finished a
love already hate and sex a the house
anything I can't get it
[Music]
okay you got a twank
hany and he can understand on it
okay
yeah yeah take this get it got perfect
yeah thank you oh crap
hey BAM bang weren't what tag is this
Dimond hey mister party
you like that another damn it wow it's
so easy getting rich here you know mr. a
van yeah yeah
have you no yeah lock and key huh same
yet the anko that's blood
that's a fake ad what what is this not
gonna the vandal time brothers yeah why
don't I got here okay what is that what
does that say
[Music]
yes can I help you
man every single game has like if we
should have one of these games has like
got a clock hate the clock ones yeah
how'd I say
nothing matches nothing get
yep
jammed us up God get again perfect
perfecto okay I like dance oh my god
what happened here they're climbing up
by then they got your hides that are
calm down
felt like a key - okay wait dad dad dad
that
it always goes to this thing great now
just kidding it's always gonna yeah and
five
8:5 perfect okay can I have my sir
and Tevin epi' I can't get get get
and it says to click on the netball
weird okay well this is to put the heart
there just kidding it's not ready yet
yeah Jesus sacrificed the family members
so he's like a killer
hey that's gotta let me die huh he's
like developing how the heck is this
thank you that's your boo boo you know
her hat no okay
okay get on our way
get out of here yeah oh yeah I'm trying
to get out
stupid bird okay here we go right a
little
let's got out yeah right here right here
you need a like a up lad
I care too boy let's say well done now I
found enough yes we were here
wait what you gotta say baby will you
marry me bra C is the answer
is that why she just had huh what is
that what the hell it's a oh if there's
a ring let's say thinking I don't know
anyways way on that way that's fine we
guys know I guess I guess without their
hey baby
come out right yeah crazy coke yeah her
eyes a cab
no right there goodness that I guess I'm
up I can't remember
I cannot remember hey like that baby
Oh F yeah Bob a Mary Mary Mary I get
this did I do this I already finished
his level okay I get get that's their
case ah well they're out wreck hello I
missed that Peggy oh and I can order
them okay wait there door days I
probably got to order this and they're
like sex yeah I probably got out of
those too okay wait
and arrow come on whereas they're always
like this uh okay
it's backwards oh crap haha this is
backwards let me just take a look can I
write this that top bottom left top
right and there's that okay and I can't
that's that I know it's right I know
it's right yeah man that case
there another is there another dot and I
my saying what hack all right okay what
is that castle not that I had I not that
I hello sir
anything up here ah my brother and I on
the final stage of finding the elixir
The Alchemist I've seen this somewhere
okay maybe I threw this one instead
circle circle like that I may have a
memory stareable okay thank uh that bats
right wait
what I put there again is it okay so
what it what is the rest anything else
yes steppin and how do you just make him
like blank right there I'm missing a
step and I get me this ah the real the
real one oh okay
okay I get it they write these down the
dots are like filling a bunch of last
time so really it's okay I got the full
picture now I was like what the hell are
the dots okay um triangle this should be
best anticipate this yeah hello yeah
what's going on out there
Palace Hotel well you guys are a play to
rescue Lake Hotel
oh this is happening at the same time
they haven't been murdered yet
interesting
what am I supposed to be doing here
though
nothing I can really do is this just
like a easter egg
there's something else that kind of you
know yeah anything out there no no what
is this white blotchy stuff okay I guess
I got to solve some of these puzzles
take it this way can I
[Music]
he's like door that is right here
[Music]
anyways okay
a surrogate fix this
[Music]
okay that it did I went that way now
there's more stuff here mm-hmm I get
that I went that I Bates again I found
like I have on oh wait no
what's this orange in here
perfect yes yes oh I got a look at okay
this is making more sense now let's see
how they are arranged okay
it is rabbit I think that's the pigeon
or maybe the pheasant I can't remember
hug crow deer vulture or checking
account no tell it is okay that's okay
here okay
rabbit
cuz here okay it's rabbit pig hog up
pitch perfect perfect and I can't how
this crazy thing
holy cannoli even know what I'm looking
at
can't tell like what's the beginning and
end now I guess these are the end points
yeah Sandpoint des is not right
perfect that's an easy one
[Music]
now you were thinking about this watch
it buddy you were dreaming about this
wow really makes no sense but okay six
seven years later childbirth she's like
I'm so prego
that's just like I need like food like
bad like like what is that a pie okay
someone left the uh someone left the tap
in the crib again okay no they all Bambi
bottles ah
they had like a French Bulldog or
something right shut your mouth you
[ __ ] um okay they wanted this mortar
Emma so he's selling that they're gonna
be born today Wayne oh oh oh she's gonna
have triplets Jesus Christ
April 26 okay it's a time there what is
that
it's 205 before I forget is there
anything there nerimon well these guys
now
perfect
whoops [ __ ] spilt [ __ ] on the floor
okay I feel like I think all right
sniper over here snap it over there can
I trim this dog eh yeah why not sure max
yeah what the slaves you went that route
or the more I can't take this no very
perplexing lives in here and this up
okay now what is that spoon that she
wanted the birth potion that's what you
wanted didn't you baby here's your love
birth potion okay here's one
yep Hey
I'm order yep okay what do you want now
[Music]
epicenter perfect she wants a bottle
anything any other very stretch out give
it that doc right you like that
regular percenter yeah I like it myself
a good percent that tell you no and okay
I guess we're gonna do this the weird
way
yeah yeah oh crap oh they all want
different things
alright who wants to blood he wants the
blood second Beth okay what is the other
ones what
milk and then flowers lady and it yeah
milk
thank you
hey Bob a okay yeah hair got the flowers
because I heart held out wait it's like
a flower and then like a poppy I don't
know what the heck that is
wait let me see is up that Jenny the
wrong thing I like a highlighter laid
out shades us these are mixed up I guess
Emma have had Albert got their stuff now
Samuel he is mal case wait like it good
yeah what nothing
duckie you gonna further use for me oh
it looks like the wallpaper wait ma'am
there you go ma'am there you go
Wow okay where is the last one got away
oh just rainwater that's messed up okay
four years later the elixir yeah they
LVAD that BAM a doc cell I've only got
let's go bring eternal life or sudden
death the alchemist it's kind of a risk
is fair hey well of he wants his
placenta you know I am what are you
thinking about
he didn't wet that all next - that's
sweet he's also like touching his balls
or something okay okay great okay all we
know is that there's five up there one
of them you do not put in okay the plus
it's one pound see we don't put that one
in but the rest is either three four
four or five okay one pound
okay that must mean the X is 500 let me
find the heaviest one
this is her best
okay so this circle must be five which
means if these dot is three squigglies
probably four and the other ones by four
that's five wait which one thing I put
okay if this is four then that means
plus and dot should equal it perfect
okay why not okay oh you got to do an
order freaking a three four four five
there a four four or five okay right
four four five
I did it
the Aquos brothers don't know who
they're the quraan the dead man that's
like talcum stems from assembled before
samsara that's what their first game
what the heck is this
don't need like a bottle or something
can't take his bowl get out of my face
my name's I put one more in there did I
get this wrong like I held on this is
plus and if this is plus then this is
three so it's four in that sideshows
equal this it seems like it's right so
far if this is five then this and that
should equal it no oh I got that wrong
if that's five then holy cannoli
x is for like an X for I might X is
definitely for and this is definitely 5
I don't know what the heck this dot is
or no this squiggly is Contech
it has to be three squiggly has to be
three then what stop
dot is something light I don't know what
that is
anyway you can make the potion now okay
so it's this guy and then two x's and
this guy what the hell
three four four five
oh there's one more time let me just
messed up 1 2 3 4
Erica yeah okay I got it right as we
test some of the dog I guess yeah uh he
left so why did he die and the dog
survived that's weird
left all sacrifices so I got a ways to
go so James is dead
not great
just right just what I needed I gotta
take out that effects
[Music]
that's his head
okay nope
[Music]
this is a crazy game
[Music]
say anyway if that time I ya broke my
heart Clarice yeah Brock my heart
[Music]
perfect okay thank you very handsome
correct and now that one of these things
yeah okay
hello sir time for your daily checkup
but there's eyes in your mouth put the
tongue in there ten sacrifices ten
family members from one word birth so if
he brings someone back
he's the dead one he died with that
poison
I knew that tongue
weird but I get it okay
I have three per finger
crap
[Music]
[Music]
we got these we get these guys out of
there
[Music]
now
there we go
[Music]
oh great that's just great dammit more
eggs this is just you know what that
says this is just professional that's
what this is great and that make it
harder I got a matte day dad may I get
harder
right I'm gonna write down here trying
to get those bellybutton
[Music]
crap
uh what the hell I don't Iike jump to
okay then we show a lot easier oh my god
[Music]
this is so easy that hey guy hey guy can
I touch that peel one more time I'll
penny up okay I got the diaper
[Music]
I got that time babe a so we're just
trying like rebirth someone right okay
my fun where the behind are like oh the
kids are back the Albert's are messed up
with drink blood
they're like I'd minding everyone I got
that hot a stick
I got that twig habit no use this
yes ass baby hey once that butterfly I
think I thought I lost that crap pen
yeah what I want he's lifting and I put
a honey in his pocket does she want
nothing marbles pot cover weird
this guy's like normal because he
actually had some like milk oh you want
a little stick here you go baby
oh you want this thing and here's your
marbles Pepe
but he's groping his sister what's going
on
Oh care about the Hat
Garrett's a happen he's like I want them
dead
i wad dad
[Music]
and I got done that I sent pretty
healthy to me it's gone out here nothing
do I just keep on shooting no maybe it's
at hey sake well well well ha-cha-cha
eliza before the Messiah here but that
like I say obey grandparents chase us
here psychopath Jim Albert you know he's
old now it supposes a birthmark he's
still thinking about God you gotta you
gotta let that butterfly go buddy blue
mask
[Music]
weird
[Music]
when I was that though okay is this
where start getting complicating how to
go like different times now I quiet
water came for the rain okay perfect
that it's got likes crazier sign that
though
Oh changes the weather
[Music]
another K nope not that one yet and
they're probably gotta tell me it did
that place move
no what the heck mr. Crowl what are you
doing okay this is kind of at like an
angle and this is like down crowd can I
hop yeah
take the whole thing
okay I can't tell this thing was kinda
like a tango and I can you change my
rock like that yeah at my sauerkraut
okay
this and that okay perfect goodbye
mister thank you for your all of your
lessons great the Moon mask guys gonna
go ballistic a psychopath anything else
are we here quick
- oh crap three two one wait 5 - 3 1 5
crap ok 5 - sorry I think one right
ok ok 5 tip really good the Ray what
he's always wanted that butterfly it's
what you always wanted ok I might start
crazy
let me see what ends up with Albert the
law The Lying Game
marry the mother Sam of the father who's
Ida
she could okay
the High Priestess always tells the
truth opposed lies chariot lies on it
once ten percent to twenty once look
outside it's to charity okay so you have
to give it to them I don't love aya my
brother is not married a card is hidden
right at the painting she loves Ida so
he's lying once okay help crap Albert
the card it's hidden right of the
painting
there's a card head in here Oh
how'd I get that Kate no there we go
there is a card
he loves Ida okay you got one lie lie
truth what's the other one
my brother is not married
how do I tell the brothers merit
wait is that Ida yeah
Samuel
that's Samuel my sister died the locker
code sister 37 that key is hidden okay
now he is true who is this guy oh crap
actually I should have looked at the
how do I go back you see who's this one
okay
Samuel same as who's there Samuel Sammy
you mad bro
I bet he's married Ida
and I know he's married not wears a hat
[Music]
brah yeah man
holy crap this is gonna be crazy did she
die now she's still alive
I think the father died
I feel like a [ __ ] alright Oh Emma yeah
she's dead she killed herself
Jesus dead she loves that Ida
she loves that Ida okay Sam real yeah
sister died it's one truth locker code
touch with three seven keys hidden in
bottom right corner so two truths
it's not married I bit this guy's to
chariot true true star through sad
thirty seven nine four crap
ah I bet they're both telling the truth
here okay
what's-her-face he was always telling
the truth
this lady telling the truth false and
what was the other one because it's not
summer the card is here behind of the
top-left corner of the photo and try to
get out here okay that was it true Jesus
what are the rules
and I tell her like married like Ida
let's say I K is headed under the
newspaper the devil has my photo in his
pocket
I don't think he's a tough although
because he told the truth cold times
she's lying your filthy lie
she is that liar nyah-nyah-nyah
okay okay I basically got this the devil
always lies she's the devil
hey I got a babay Epps
the high priestess is Samuel now chair
this is us
I get how the way
now get these backwards look it outside
nothing happening we just make sure he's
always soldier this sister Dodd yes yes
and yes okay so he is definitely good
lie lie
hi there's no key right no key here
nothing nothing
okay she has got to be the devil
I'm not sure about the chariot and the
Empress
he lied I don't know how you told this
one card has hit true true so he lied
once there on the right spot
[Music]
she only lied once how do you get uh
wait
this may be true two compartments for
sex
no choose a liar she's a liar and a
thief keep saying to look outside and
I'm looking outside how do you like
finalise the game
there are numbers
I don't know I don't know oh wait this
might not be Emma that's me Ida and then
we could be the wedding photo so they
did get married so he has a false well
okay all right so maybe he actually is
the devil
okay let's switch it up real quick
now she told you it once yep all right
go okay what am I supposed to do with
this put it on this dead
you love masks I really want to find out
what happens to that guy he's crazy
ooh Albert is still in love with Ida uh
uh yeah he wants them gone
this guy is straight-up crazy hey sighs
i nato wales hello master
I guess I'm mrs. Ida and this says his
crazy brother way about way my webbing
anything has pockets anything extra okay
hey it's two wheels
right
Wow okay hold on the one with the arm
that goes up I'm just kidding I have no
idea okay her arms like this and she's a
straight face this crib Amy Isaac he's
thinking of being shocked and she's
thinking of being shocked is that kind
of happiness huh
I have no idea well that's what creepy
yet lasted so long yeah like this Dan
with his candle sir this is her and
she's a straight face
oh I think I got to make them how they
are over there that was correct
holy Toledo abscess sorry sir he's like
I guess Oh
it freaked out because he's sick
controlling them
[Music]
I gotta just their arms
so what are gonna do with this middle
guy his Hanna's be up
this is so weird
[Music]
thready lights more stuff
[Music]
what the heck oh he knocked this down
whoo Oh eyes now sir plays now probably
the other thing but it's out of sorry I
had say
sit that just dead
it's a good knee here I could do she's
dead so he actually killed her
[Music]
what not to and what's the whales
[Music]
that's just alive the eyes change the
eyes do not change didn't no longer
thinking anything his eyes are open
I have to put him in a wood position I
think
[Music]
okay her mother's open
I got it open
uh okay so when I put it like this the
mouth is open right now
yeah how do I get his mouth open
just right and left you see his mouth
open here no
nope I guess you got to put them in that
position so she's calm here what is he
like here
he's come there no space hasn't changed
Oh
what is it here
right now I'm so confused oh my god wait
on it's like this I don't know what this
is
down and up
[Music]
to open as well
when she goes like that what does it
make
[Music]
fascinating oh my gosh took out a
freaking eye oh my god oh my god
great we got two eyes this is crazy okay
I guess he like killed him right Chai's
he'll part the brood this guy is so
crazy
he wants a jar what's in a head bro he's
a skinny bean blood bile fan okay so the
first thing he wants is a pain where are
the brains potato egg that's a peg I say
like trying to cows I
the penis first how do I get this over
there okay
I say now
perfect drop it okay now I need the
blood Irene I just water that's just
water and baby yeah yeah yeah you're
talking about crazy stuff
did that work and I got shot
oh there we go okay I got the water here
you got the water
okay next
is get in this thing in here how do like
I need delight this potato weight
guarantee this goes here yeah it's gotta
light it okay where well where does the
potato cow I probably give him right
here
hey bro take this potato yeah he wants a
jar what the heck is that pot what's
semen okay by the cement on her sir did
you have like a plan with this a minute
how's that plan to go along with this Oh
see man that goes in there
okay put the same in there okay
oh he's like trying to have a baby with
Ida okay
so he took I'd his egg like literally
like an ovary okay and then that in
water how I am
let's did you like in prison his brother
well he just littered had a baby with
Ida rose
[Music]
yeah bow yes Sam
oh crap it needs to be a certain one
thank you how this utter all this this
my name is Anna has been a I'm a William
[Music]
yep had it today Eclair this chaste kiss
she's kind of farther away right
well yeah as van der boom
[Music]
do you like it yes what do you want
hose n hair left I want laugh
timepieces oh I'm gonna go back at that
place
sacrifices it up a bit up a Pump It Up
pump it says baby and a nose fancier
watches okay
[Music]
the well part to this girl is crying for
sure she's like hmm I matter well
[Music]
cup where me where me do this dog still
live it's like 30 years cap and I quit
can't put liquid and anything back eller
here anything at all DNA to be
framemeister really Dan a life
all right okay get the tray
we're obviously rows things up in here
teca's s please help me yes drink I need
a drink
I need food I need a stick and I had to
get out there's someone in there
drink that up s yeah yeah yeah Jane that
I get paid yes BAE BAE yeah how do you
like your newfound rank okay yeah that's
what does that mean he needs food now
all right I'll eat the dog now okay
okay that I got lucky
yeah I kind of like a there I got to cut
this Jesus and I got a cactus down I I
gotta cut this and I cut that I know you
got a match on you you psychopath
anything I can hear his hair
[Music]
that way that's convenient
[Music]
there you go buddy
don't say I never helped you okay can't
man that stuff back delicious that
wouldn't stick there you go buddy is
that that sec imprisoned this must be
the end
checkmate Albert didn't Frank who the
heck is Frank this potato guy he wants
our dad for imprisoning him he wants him
dead hour
what do you want he wants him dad only
one well laugh
[Music]
sorry bro so when I get to the brain
he's the king
[Music]
like an ally what the hell he's a king
now can I got this
so Ray Brown okay wait it goes down up
down down up up down down up down up
okay compadres and you're like I like
stuck like that very stretch yep can
only move it one place I think they make
elves one thing
he what he is the king you should really
be ashamed of yourself what ray
for where's the app
you know I'm on this thing now the M is
this thing Jesus
okay say hey ah hey
Bay are
yeah well I gotta go backwards
okay wait did this one or I'll let me
just move backwards it has to be this
you which means it has to be this R
which means it has to be where is there
an A
it has to be this you so it has to be
this are which me has to be this be
which means it has to be this three
couple you see now it can't be that a
you see
okay
[Music]
there we go what the heck
okay I guess we're taking as brain that
is the end of Albert I have no idea
Frank is so I'm wait I'm going back
holy cannoli okay let's get away from
Albert real quick and let's go to this
girl she killed herself
right now it's Samuel look at the girl
that killed herself this is a my ended
up killing herself
fertility how that was their big sorry
missed some of the flowers
[Music]
she needs one okay I don't do that Freya
baby but don't say I never helped you
[Music]
wait what was that it's a one excellent
one of those things which is this guy
what the hell
what the heck
I'm back now they show what this puzzle
is
mr. BAE can you help us here oh oh wait
it should be red and yellow
now
what's the heck
[Music]
how do you
[Music]
something here am I saying well this
place is like so old now crazy
one yellow to red
wait how am I missing something
how'd you do this
don't know how to do this no no no
oh okay it turns out I hit the wrong
thing okay signature read terms I had
that equipped it's annoying
oh it actually transforms it and stuff
[ __ ] no it's a bit green around I need
to leave okay
holy cannoli that was [ __ ] actually have
a B you never - how the hell do you make
- crap ton of red
okay I think it's a little bit of blue
in there up
absolutely not did I kill this thing man
dad okay let's do this over again people
I don't know what that is Oh close
cut this
oops that's why I was so confusing I had
the stupid thing clicked
how
maybe take an order
blowing up what is assistance is red
maybe it's two Reds and a yellow take
very light okay
it's red blue yellow or maybe it's just
two yellows in a room in a red whose tax
at me I don't know we're ahead
yellow what the hell is that
[Music]
blue blue all right
who came close
I made that one okay huh yeah yellow
yellow red hello
what the hell
yeah Wow Wow crap
Jesus Christ let me thank here let me
think here dude
blue red not red finally now she wants
three and I made three before three was
red I think it was two blues
and this green oh and it's just that
curly thing okay yeah you got lighting
[Music]
for oh my god okay I think I've gotten
that it's definitely this thing yellow
and kind of blue there's no real light
red in there oh my God thank God
they're letting that's a stupid thing
J's like do you want a baby or something
mm-hmm
you